Je suis prêtre et je m'entraîne et j'ai
des tatouages ​​et c'est peut-être
intéressant pour les gens
[Musique] c'est une
question de foi
et aussi beaucoup de santé et comment nous
voyons la santé et comment nous pourrions travailler sur notre
propre santé et c'est tout  tout simplement pas
à propos de vous connaissez notre santé physique mais
aussi notre santé existentielle notre santé mentale [
Musique]
et beaucoup de gens ont posé des questions
sur mes routines et programmes d'entraînement,
donc j'essaie de mettre quelque chose là-bas
après chaque session afin que les gens puissent
suivre si  ils veulent et généralement c'est
quelque chose avec des kettlebells quelque chose de
cardio quelque chose pour augmenter votre rythme cardiaque
merci
[Musique]
ici en Suède je ne sais pas vraiment
ce n'est pas un gros problème ici il y a plus de
prêtres qui sont comme
les gens ordinaires
alors nous '  re assez utilisé avec les prêtres à
cœur sont différents
merci
Dieu est dans tous les aspects de ma vie je
pense que quand je travaille c'est aussi
quelque part une interaction relationnelle une
prière avec Dieu
mais aussi en rencontrant d'autres personnes en
rencontrant d'autres personnes ici  à l'
hôpital où je travaille
euh c'est aussi en quelque sorte une relation
et une rencontre avec Dieu pour qu'une partie de
moi ma foi soit toujours avec moi dans
tout ce que je fais donc je ne peux pas séparer ça
des autres choses
[Musique]